- What is that?
(happy upbeat music)
- Four out of five.
- I give it a five.
- It looks really good.
- There's a lot of sprinkles.
- Lots of sprinkles.
- It's a square with bubblegum on it.
- Look a bit weird and
then it taste good again.
- It tastes like rotten potatoes.
- Four.
- I would give it seven out of five stars.
- I would definitely eat that
again, that's really good.
- I love it.
(crowd applauding)
- I would taste.
- I don't wanna eat it, this is so cute.
- I like the style.
- So, it's too much sweet stuff,
and I don't really like it.
- Five on five.
- I'll give it a three.
- Yeah, that's really, really good.
- Oh, I think it, I
oh, yeah, I don't think
it's gonna taste delicious.
(buzzer buzzing)
- I really like about it is the jelly.
- Jelly was good.
- It's really different.
- And it has like a kick to it.
- It tastes like bubble gum.
- Tastes good.
- I like it.
- Scale one to five?
Two.
- I would definitely eat it again.
- Five.
(happy upbeat music)
- It's just like an oatmeal cookie.
I like this one.
- Tasted worst.
(buzzing sound)
- Good.
- I'd give a five, five, five.
- Probably a five.
- And I give it a four.
- I think Australian biscuits are,
it's like an American food, sort of, but
these add different flavors to them.
- I think they're very, very good.
- They're great.
- Jelly and biscuits are awesome.
- I'll finish it.
- Alrighty.
Or give it to my Mom.
- Your Mom will have one
so, you can finish it.
- Okay.
- Is it good?